okay so I'm in this super boring meeting  about something I don't know wasn't  paying attention then BOOM  it was like an ugly contest where  everyone was a winner this one news oh  wow so I shot him then I shot this other  one shot a couple extra guys just to be  saved  sheesh I did it I did a lot of shooting  I'm being totally honest then they  destroyed my favorite store second  favorite there's that spicy ramen shop  I'm getting sidetracked look long story  short I get busy and I'm thinking I've  got this you know when you're in that  you got I got this but man I so did not  have it huh yes you had to be there  better get back to it  okay any business guy has one drink  coming  [Music]